well he's my hero chris hemsworth dishes  on helping Powell at Tom Holland land  his role in spider-man we worked on in  the hard-to-see together obviously then  through Avengers and as they were  casting him for spider-man you know I  did what I could do and made a call and  said he's one of the most talented  people I've worked with and was such a  big heart and appreciation and and I  don't we have a great friendship you  know it's a good mutual respect I'm  driving he caught up with Chris at the  New York premiere of his new film men in  black International where he walked the  carpet with his gorgeous and supportive  wife Elsa it's all about that that the  friendship first and the sense of  adventure that I think that's why we  both you know she became an action star  became an actor was just sort of travel  the world and have occurrences like this  and to have such wonderful support from  one another but also that people you're  surrounded by is the dream  [Applause]